نشاهد معكم اذا متابعينا هذه الصور من
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم حيث تتصاعد
اعمده الدخان في مناطق مختلفه مراسل عربيه
يقول ان الاشتباكات تدور في شمال العاصمه
الخرطوم وفي جنوبها ايضا اعمده الدخان
تتصاعد واصوات الدوي اطلاق النار ايضا
يتصاعد بشكل عنيف في هذه المناطق اضافه
الى اعمده الدخان بعض المصادر تتحدث عن ان
هذه الاشتباكات تدور في منطقه
المدينه الرياضيه او السوق المركزي وهي من
المناطق المكتظه بالسكان وفيها اسواق
شعبيه ايضا هناك حاله اذا من الهلع والخوف
في هذه المناطق وفي معظم مناطق السودان
خاصه في مروي ايضا التي
يشعر فيها الناس بكثير من الهلع والخوف
وقاموا بحصى مراسل العربيه باخلاء باخلاء
الشوارع وايضا وسط انتشار مكثف في القوات
الجيش في مدينه مروي ايضا المشاهدين هذه
الصور متداوله من العاص مه الخرطوم ونشاهد
فيها اعمده الدخان على صعيد الاشتباكات
الدائره الان بحسب مراسل العربيه بين قوات
الدعم السريعه وقوات الجيش السوداني ايضا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات